as western powers step up diplomatic
efforts to diffuse tensions with moscow
over ukraine european union foreign
ministers met in brussels after talks
joined by the u.s secretary of state by
video call the eu's top diplomat said
that should russia invade ukraine the
bloc would impose sanctions although he
refused to give more detail
we reaffirm
our full and
unquestionable support to ukraine
and that any military aggression against
ukraine will have serious consequences
and massive costs for the perpetrator
earlier the head of the eu commission
announced an emergency financial package
to help kiev
i am announcing a new financial
assistance package to the country
made both of emergency loans and grants
first of all the commission proposes a
new emergency macro financial assistance
package of 1.2 billion euros
this package will help ukraine now
to address its financing needs due to
the conflict
meanwhile the head of nato said the
alliance would reinforce its deployments
in eastern europe with troops ships and
fighter jets a response said yen
stoltenberg to the deteriorating
security situation
we are considering to further enhance
our presence in the eastern part of the
alliance
this could include the deployment of
additional nato battle groups
the move by nato has angered the kremlin
it denies accusations by western powers
that it is planning an attack kremlin
spokesperson dmitry peskov said
we are seeing statements from the north
atlantic alliance about more troops
pushing forces and assets onto the
eastern flank it is all causing tensions
to rise i'd like to point out it is not
because of what we russia are doing it's
all happening because of what nato and
the united states are doing and the
information they are spreading
in kiev the us and uk began the
withdrawal of some diplomats families
and non-essential workers from the city
although the embassies will remain open
the reduction of embassy staff another
sign that without a diplomatic
breakthrough the threat of conflict
looms large natasha butler al jazeera